[Music]
the issues related to
artificial intelligence are at the heart of the activities
of the hysterical artist the institute
has strong expertise in this
field
coupled with solid knowledge in these
small is an important
system culture it is this  combination of
skills but also of talent that
makes it systems a
key player in
artificial
intelligence most of our r&d projects, for
example in the fields of
predictive maintenance,
cybersecurity or autonomous vehicles,
call on this set of
technologies to support the
deployment of our work towards the
market we had to address the
issues related to trusted AI
today engineering is very
well structured with
well-defined bodies of knowledge and models
but artificial intelligence  has
completely changed the game
the community agree that neural
network-based approaches
are very  s effective but
insufficient in terms of explanatory skills
and quality of decision-making outside the
often very restricted areas of use
the hybridization of
learning models with physical models
or with the business knowledge
of experts then appears as a
real opportunity  to make the
most of reading the
complementarity between these three
approaches is undoubtedly the key
to improving the results and the
quality of the learning models
it is therefore quite natural that system
x has taken up this subject via its
artificial intelligence program  and
augmented engineering there are two and of
course via the confidence program hi hi
systemx plays a special role within
the program in addition to being a contributor
in the same way as the other partners
the state has chosen our institute to lead
and coordinate this program  which
corresponds to the technological pillars of the
certified secure grand challenge and to
make the basic systems more reliable  dice on
artificial intelligence
this is one of the reasons why
we find the systemic dm2 of a
confidence and in particular the
multi-sector and interdisciplinary approaches
system x is proud to pilot this
program is to be a
stakeholder in  a unique collective of
industrial and academic players who have
the strong ambition to forge the engineering
of tomorrow capable of integrating
AI into industrial systems with confidence this
is a major challenge for the
sovereignty and competitiveness of  our
industries
[Music]